[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you on Thursday the
12th of January I'm John Connolly The
Spectators news editor and your host
this week
coming up on the show
who's afraid of kirst armor Fraser
Nelson writes in this week's cover piece
that the Tories will find it hard to
demonize the labor leader in the same
way as his predecessors phrase will be
on the show with Matthew Goodwin
does Rishi sunak have a plan to stop the
small boats crisis Katie balls asked
whether fixing the problem could be key
to helping the conservatives win back
voters Katie and Stephen Bush will join
me
Prince Harry's new Memoir spare was
released this week Harry describes doing
drugs losing his virginity and falling
out with his brother what Nerf was he
thinking I'll speak to petronella Wyatt
and David abalafia
in this week's magazine Owen Matthews
explains why Putin's plan to freeze
Europe this winter failed Russia risks a
repeat of the 1990s he says with
becoming a failed State he'll join the
show
and finally Tarantino can make films but
can he write John Mayer reviews the
director's new book Cinema speculation
in this week's magazine and will be on
the show to tell us what he thought
before we get going thank you to
kanacore genuity wealth management for
sponsoring this episode of the week in
60 minutes can Accord are experienced
wealth planners and investment managers
who offer unwavering support in
challenging times visit cando wealth.com
for more information
and if you enjoy spectator TV then do
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon so
you never miss an episode
first up would care stamma be such a bad
prime minister Fraser Nelson the
spectator's editor wonders if there's
really any difference between him and
Rishi sunak the Tories after all seem to
have completely run out of ideas to
explain Fraser joins me now alongside
Matthew Goodwin the academic and
pollster
Fraser Matthew thank you for joining us
on spectator TV now Fraser you write in
a magazine this week that the Tories
have lost one of the most potent weapons
when it comes to labor can you uh tell
us a bit about that please well through
quite a few years now the conservative
is a major weapon in election campaigns
was asking workers to be very afraid of
the other guy now when the other guy was
Jeremy corbyn that didn't need much
elaboration you had people like Ian
Austin them quitting as labor MP to vote
against him Jeremy corbyn but previously
you had let's be worried about red Aid
in the Coalition of chaos
Etc so traditionally when you look at
what the conservatives stand for as a
party they're pretty ideologically Flex
what they stand for is keeping the other
guys out of power that has been the
traditional conservative Rule now this
works if the other guy is Scary or can
be made seem to be scary and I look
right now in this kind of story that how
cures to armor is many many things you
might say he's dull and that happens a
memorable thing in three years but it's
difficult to say that he is a real and
present threat to the United Kingdom and
the way that they were able to say about
Jeremy corbyn now that is a problem for
the Tories because for so long they've
become I think a bit lazy and not really
making the positive Arguments for
conservatism but not really believing or
defining what they stand for or why
somebody should choose them rather than
somebody else they've just said the
other guy's awful but now they're going
to have to fall back on why they are
very good at what what they have to
offer why somebody should actively want
a fifth conservative term and there I
think they're running into some problems
not simply because like here Stoner is
hard to caricature Captain is where
Street is proving a plausible NHS
reformer he's taking flank the health of
the unions and then you've got John
Ashworth those Shadow work and pension
secretary he was giving a speech to Ian
Duncan Smith's Center for social justice
a few days ago and the language he was
using struck me as exactly the language
that IDs used against Gordon Brown look
at these five million people on welfare
isn't it a scandal it's a waste of human
life not just a waste of money these
used to be totally attacked Lion's use
of a government so you can see things
moving full circle we haven't looked at
labor for a while because and I think it
was time to look in this cover piece
that this is a party which isn't just
going through the motions of change they
are doing policy changes as well and if
you're a wavering voter there isn't very
much right now to be obviously afraid of
and Massey do you agree with that
assessment do you think voters kind of
don't have anything to fear from labor
anymore
I do uh agree uh broadly with Fraser's
piece and I I've been thinking much the
same recently when it comes to the ideas
on on things like the NHS on
um the economy
um labor also in brexit by the way uh
accepting essentially where we are with
brexit labor in a much stronger position
than they were and this is reflected in
just how weak the conservative brand has
become I mean the remarkable fact about
British politics today is that the
conservative party does not own a single
major issue in British politics there is
one exception which is defense uh but to
be frank voters don't really uh think
about the fence when they're voting uh
at The Ballot Box they think about the
economy they think about the NHS they
think about immigration inflation the
cost of living or none of those issues
that the conservative party holder lead
so you go back to you know the Blair
years of Thatcher years and the message
from all of that data is quite clear the
parties the own the big Salient issues
of the parties that win elections so so
that I I completely agree with I I
suppose where I might push back a little
bit perhaps is
I still believe that while starma has
done everything he needs to do to get
labor into power
I still think he's vulnerable I still
think that if you look at sama's ratings
there are a few things that if I was in
stalma's office would probably be
keeping me up at night only about
one-third of the country today say they
trust kiosama uh his competency ratings
meaning the share of people who say I
think this guy is competent they've
basically been flatlining at quite low
levels and and more voters tend to
dislike Sama
um than like him and more people tend to
say he doesn't look like a prime
minister in Waiting than say he does now
yes he's doing the things he needs to do
but I think he's still seen by a large
majority of the country actually
um with suspicion uh a sense they're not
entirely sure whether this guy has moved
on from the the years the very four
years of the the brexit uh referendum
and its aftermath and that if the
conservatives are clever
um and Fraser I completely agree with I
mean they've made a number of mistakes
and they might not be up up to this task
but if they are clever they may well
actually be able to exploit some of that
in the context of a general election
campaign president do you think that's
something the Tories can do or do you
think they're too lost at sea at the
moment to kind of put together a
strategy for the next election like that
I think it is very much something they
can do as long as they stop thinking
about themselves I mean right now they
have been fighting each other for a long
long time uh the skiru Stormer has not
had to attack conservatives at all
because they've been doing it to
themselves if you look at the opinion
pool lead now stormers on broadly
speaking 20 points and you have to go
back I think it was only once in
post-war history has an opposition gone
to lose the next election after being so
far ahead but that was Neil kinnick
against John Major so Tory's have done
this before they can do it again now
cure starbur is was it mildly not the
most formidable leader of the labor has
ever had
um he's hard to hate and I think people
underestimate that I mean take Joe Biden
for example not the most charismatic
president but America just thought
needed that after the exhaustion of the
Trump drama now perhaps I think of the
exhaustion of the Tory leadership
psychodrama they might need somebody a
little bit boring sometimes a lecturers
can see being boring as a virtue but
because starmer himself is playing it
safe and all he's really doing is sort
of touching the Tory errors in front of
him he isn't really coming out with a an
inspiring agenda to vote for labor he
and that gives the conservatives an
opportunity if they can actually think
of an inspiring pro-tory message then
they might not get much pushback it may
well be that cure starmer is simply
geared up to be be the receptacle of
Tory protests but isn't really
um psychologically suited to go out
there and win converts in the way that
Tony Blair was able to win quite
enthusiastic converts to the Blair
project so this is very reversible for
the conservatives but I think they would
have to to to recover they'd have to get
out of the head the idea that labor is
unelectable labor is is very likable
right now I think we're streating in
John Ashraf for example are serious
skies and sincere in their desire to
reform public services in Rachel Reeves
you've got somebody who says she doesn't
want to increase income tax and in
Jeremy Hunt you've got a chancellor who
wants to put tanks and spending to the
highest level in post-war history labor
oratory so so right now you know there
are there is scope for a slightly better
offer than what we're getting here right
now if the conservatives can make that
better offer than Grace but they haven't
got much time
and Matthew um impresses PC mentions
something that the toys of squandered is
the fact that they've raised the tax
burden to sort of record highs
um do you get a sense that's a loss to
opportunity as well for the Tories
yeah I mean I think the
the key point we need to remember is
that the economic context
if I'm right at least is going to change
radically over the next 12 months
um inflation we can already see has has
probably peaked will start to fall
through
23. interest rates will will start to
come down significantly I think
um the energy bills will not be as high
as people feared last winter we can
already see some of that the cost of
living crisis will by the end of the
year I suspect be a lot
um a lot less pressing than it feels
currently all of that politically will
allow Rishi soon act to get into The
Narrative of uh things are getting
better we're over the worst of it uh
let's not take a risk now on on a new
government let's not take a gamble I
think he will also be hoping alongside
that that the legislation and the the
changes around migration and the small
boats which remember is a top two issue
for conservatives it's the second issue
for for the 2019 conservative so that is
bearing Fruit by the spring and the
summer so again he can say look things
are starting to change do you really
trust labor on this issue and the short
answer I can tell you from my polling is
no laborer is still deeply vulnerable on
the migration question uh less so on the
economy but but they are vulnerable on
the on that question and the third Point
here that I think
may end up helping sooner more than we
currently anticipate is that even still
if you look at 2019 conservative voters
only about 15 to 20 percent of those
voters are defecting to labor uh the
vast majority who have left the
conservative party such a number now
saying they don't know who they're going
to vote for they're sitting it out uh
midterm Blues are sitting in out they're
probably alienated by the tax increases
they're alienated by which is soon act
they don't like the way Boris Johnson
was seemingly thrown out of power
um but they aren't switching on mass to
labor yet the numbers who are is is
beginning to tick up but but overall
most of them are sitting out that to me
alongside this changing economic context
gives team sunac an opportunity whether
they can reinvent their message and
their their brand as we go into that
next election remains to be seen But
there is an opportunity emerging on the
horizon and I think we do well to take
seriously and Fraser one of those sort
of attack we could say Richie sunax
first of mini relaunch came earlier this
year with sort of five targets that he
set himself uh one of which was the
small boats that Matthew mentioned there
do you think that's the kind of right
strategy the right the right approach no
that was dismal when I thought that was
I'm trying to break out of such a word
as a d-launch
worse than where he was before and he
came up with these five pledges seeing
no tricks as far as I could work out
it's almost every single one of them was
a trick and it seemed to be an
astonishing lack of ambition saying he
wants to grow the economy well everybody
in the two-year period is for the last
500 years has grown the economy he says
he wants to um decrease debt but he's
got no plans to do that so that was
incorrect might even call it a lie and
if he says he wants to have inflation
well inflation is going to happen in
Britain in America in Israel in Canada
and France and Germany any one of those
leaders could have sted up and said you
know I intend to have inflation this
year but they didn't because it would
have been disingenuous so to see Rishi
sinek reaching for these Gordon Brown
style tools of desperation was what made
me write this cover story in the first
place I looked at it this is incredibly
complacent of the Tories if you think
this staggeringly unambitious platform
because in any way be described as a
pledge the only ambitious thing they
mentioned was stopping the small boats
stopping a small boats not reducing The
Landings by half now there's no way he's
going to be able to if he is I will take
my hat off to him so it seemed to me to
be four fantasies and an undeliverable
and that is his New Year's resolution
for 2023 it's going to be very difficult
um year of the tourism did thank you
Fraser and thank you Matthew
Katie Bulls the spectator's political
editor writes in this week's magazine
that tackling the small boats crisis
might be the best way for the government
to win the public back over to discuss
sunak's plan Katie joins me now
alongside Steven Bush associate editor
of the financial times
Katie and Stephen thank you for joining
us on spectator TV now Katie Wright in
this week's magazine about the fact that
despite some sort of public support for
Rishi sunak and his new five pledges
there's a lot of murmings of discontent
on the Tory back benches can you uh tell
us a bit about that please yeah I mean
this is nothing particularly new in
terms of the Tory party and their
leaders particularly in recent years
um but I think yes we should see Knack
brought a sense of stability back or
relative sense
um after a really terribly year but
already you'll stand to hear you know
back Ventures complaining some ministers
so I think the five priorities there's
definitely one school of thought that
this is good um it's what races are
actually talking about when it comes to
those main issues so cost of living the
state of the NHS so I think any tool for
that isn't particularly good for the
Tories but the state of the NHS and then
of course small boats but also you are
hearing plenty of other tourists say
where is the big vision and are you just
repeating what you hear in a focus group
um and I think one Minister said to me
and this is a pointless speech which
suggests that we are pointless and and
therefore what does Rishi sunak do at a
time when I think I think it's safe to
say lots of tourists feel pretty
uninspired and almost writing off the
next election to try and bring his party
back together Stephen decent their
writer to be uninspired by RCC night do
you think they're right about this
criticisms of his sort of lack of vision
there uh well yes and no right so so yes
right these are five pledges that are
well one of them is not the government
you know one of them is a target with
Central Bank one of them is like saying
I pledged an under the conservatives in
two years time will all be two years
older well yeah of course that's how
time works
um and the other three are ones which
again it's very easy to see how they
will be met and so you can see how
um that fits into an election campaign
going you know the worst is the worst
has happened things are turning the
corner don't let labor ruin it
um now I would say a reasonable argument
for why conservative MPS should feel
nervous about that it is is that it is
identical to the the campaign the John
Major 4 in 1997 at a time with a much
better economy right yeah broadly
speaking in 97. anyone believes that any
set of policy choices would get get you
to the economy uh John Major was
overseeing in 1997 by the back end of
2024. but the reason why I also say no
is that I do sometimes feel a little bit
um when I hear conservative MPS talk
about Richie so now it's like hearing
someone who drove their car into the
wall then peed all over the burning car
a mechanic has finally arrived and they
just I still don't have a functioning
vehicle that's right well it was a lot
worse before he started yeah these
things broadly speaking we've now got to
a point where conservative MPS are often
quite churlishly at going oh we might
lose the next election it's like I mean
guys a couple of months ago it was a
question whether or not You'd Survive
the next election so yes they do have
these problems yes it is hard to see
from here how they could turn it turn it
around
but fairly obviously uh they now have
um in Richardson Jeremy Hunt their best
available candidates for those two top
jobs uh so yeah and Katie you say in
your column you know one of the issues
that one of the pledges that is a bit
more difficult for them to do is or
remarkably more difficult to do is the
small boats issue can you tell us a bit
about sort of the Divine inventory party
about whether this is a good idea
whether they should be yeah so I think
within the Tory party there is
actually on all the issues where there's
Unity there is Unity that this is a good
idea to stop the boats the question is
how do you do it yeah how do you phrase
it and therefore again it's slightly to
that point which I think Steven's
completely correct about of um the fact
that lots of Tori MP is very quick to
criticize where she's unacca and you
know things have come before uh which
have had an effect today but on the one
hand they're unambitious targets people
say well inflation is going to come down
anyway that's Global that's not really
do Rishi sunak um figures the number 10
would disagree and on the other hand
I'll say well stop the boats that's way
too ambitious we're you know making
ourselves a hostage for fortune
um and I think when it comes to boats
what racially effectively needs to do is
keep his party really behind him not in
a way I don't think where she's doing
its position right now is at risk
despite lots of talking yeah the return
of Boris Johnson which I think we're
probably just gonna have to live with
being a theme for basically this year
and maybe every year to come and no
matter what happens to the Tory party
um but I think he needs to offer some
hope or purpose to his back benches so
they feel they have a common cause and I
think the priorities to give them
something they can talk about but I
think small boats have been Downing
Street is seen as something where
actually you could unite the party
around it um to to this idea of a shared
Mission and one of the things will be um
in the next four weeks we're expecting
it this new legislation that Richardson
has talked about and which is to
strengthen the laws bringing new laws
which will make it easier in their minds
to actually stop those arriving in small
boats when we're deporting um whether
it's Toronto where it's back to a safe
country and once you have that
legislation in the house can you make a
fight because you want to unite the Tory
party but you also want to divide labor
and I think lots of them are saying what
makes them so uncomfortable is just how
confident labor are at the moment you
look in the Commons chamber you look at
kids dominant prime minister's questions
the fact that Kirsten is very happy to
go at immigration just point to the
Tories record so they want to somehow
turn the tables on that and I think if
you know labor do oppose this
legislation which I think is the working
assumption in Government Can you start
to weaponize that and if the law told it
up can you start to say well look we
have a plan but these various groups are
disrupting it and use that as a dividing
line because what is the dividing line
for the tourism labor at the next
election I mean Fraser Nelson for the
cover this week talks about why
um actually
is there much reason to be afraid of
kirst armor he finds that um the
argument you would have heard about
Jeremy corbyn don't work I mean I was
speaking to one senior Tori he said the
problem is the three reasons I won the
2019 election are gone
um and that was getting brexit done
Boris Johnson and Jeremy corbyn all
coming together and so they need
something new to say and I think there
there is a sense that of all the things
if you look at the state of the economy
but also the fact there aren't so many
dividing lines right now between labor
and the Tories
um immigration could be where you could
find one on that point Stephen
um if labor do find themselves on the
opposite of the dividing line
particularly about deportations to
Rwanda do you think they'd be
comfortable there
um or do you think there's sort of a
vulnerability for labor there
no I mean to be honest although like you
know obviously Katie Remains the the
impeccable Source about what goes on
within the conservative party's
governing mind and you do hear that
exactly that argument made
look the reason why small boats are
politically painful for the government
is they are they're failing right uh and
broadly speaking it's expensive to to
get you know to get to a point where
well what you're never going to get to a
point where there's zero illegal
movement into your into your country the
only way to be a country where there
isn't a legal movement where there
aren't people seeking to come uh and
claim Asylum is to be a country people
want to claim Asylum from right and
again unfortunately it's out with the
ability capabilities of government to
get to that point in two years where you
could get is a place where you can at
least say we are successfully
regularizing the status of more people
in the immigration system on any given
day than there are people coming in Via
small boats but if you were to do that
you would have to be stepping up our
enforcement of illicit practices in the
labor market stepping up our enforcement
of you know various Petty crimes because
of course most of the criminal gangs
that do these activities you know they
have Diversified portfolios as it were
they aren't just doing people
trafficking they're also doing drug
trafficking and other offenses that we
we don't chase down and I think labor
will feel very well labor feel very
confident than they are on the right
side of the BET going look we're going
to oppose this saying it's not going to
work you're going to run around bringing
people's attention to the fact and then
you're in a mess and it's not going to
work and we will still be able to say at
the back end of 2024 this didn't work
now of course viewers with long memories
will go isn't that the gamble that they
played on the economy in 2012 which
didn't work out for them in 2015. that
that would be the situation in which it
backfired for them but obviously up
until the point that happens they'll
feel confident then it won't and I think
you can see that in the sense when it
comes to the Rwanda scheme specifically
labor have attacked it but they've
attacked it on functionality workability
and they've actually tried to say to
those who are listening don't attack it
on moral grounds and stick to this
competence argument because they know as
soon as you get into that that's
actually where I think the labor party
will be divided potentially to the
voters they want to win at the next
election and be going off message there
so so while they can say it doesn't work
and I think that this is a comfortable
position for later but the question is
canax show enough progress
um in terms of you know perhaps a bit
optimistically I mean number 10 really
are better in the house and delivery so
they say you know it's all still to play
for and but delivery is anyway we're
gonna win the next election but they
want to find some metrics to point you
to say We'll look actually on albanians
we have done this here we have done that
so stick with us
if there isn't enough progress there'll
also be an internal argument of
inventory party because there is a
school of thought which dates back I
think to some who are involved with the
vote leave campaign and this is also an
idea everything considered by some
during the shortly lived trust
Premiership which is
why is the Rwanda scheme not working one
of the reasons at the moment and yes you
recently had a court judgment saying it
is lawful but if you can't get it to
work with various changes that we're
seeing now I think pressure will grow
and you've already had some story about
benches for the UK to pull out the echr
now the argument goes we should have
actually MPS in different places and
some and some government advisors so
this is not government policy and I
don't really want to do this right now
is that you could put it in the
manifesto the general election becomes a
de facto referendum on the East Asia R
and therefore you have a you know get
the boats done type pitch which is we're
we've got half the policy using how all
these vessels are trying to stop it and
vote for us and we'll actually do
everything we can to make sure it really
happens then there are some problems
with that but people will say well it is
a dividing line um and you can see the
way that brexit was put on the agenda um
in the similarities and that could work
Stephen well
I mean I I doubt it not least because I
think the central biggest mistake than
um the sort of continuity remain
campaign made in the 2017-2019
parliament is that they visibly were the
problem whereas it feels to me that the
risk with this dividing line of oh you
put it in the manifesto and you go get
the boat start in this one at that point
the line to take from the government
will be we haven't been able to get a
grip of this problem
um for the whole of the parliament
we're proposing that we would make
ourselves a pariah in Europe
um than we would you know join join
Russia and Belarus in not being in the
echr we've spent Millions upon millions
of pounds and you know and I mean if we
are yeah if the government is very lucky
they may have sent what as many as five
people to Rwanda some of whom will come
back right as as we saw when Israel
tried to to have a have a sustained
policy
um I think essentially the as Casey says
the big the big bet here is delivery I
am not convinced that an election
dividing line based on the idea that
with a large majority the government has
failed to deliver on this issue that it
won't shut up about is a is a good move
however I think the interesting question
is I don't think any of us can say for
sure what does count as delivery on this
it's possible Right than even one
successful flight to Rwanda would change
how people perceive the government's
handling of immigration I don't know if
that's the case but if if overnight that
one flight means that we see from voters
going like it in theory but you can't do
it and you're rubbish to like it in
theory love it in practice then suddenly
this dividing line becomes very powerful
thank you Stephen and thank you Katie
Prince Harry's book spare gives
excruciating details about his and his
family's lives King Charles wasn't
always a great father to him William and
Kate put him to wear that and that's the
uniform and Camilla always wanted to be
a queen according to Harry this week's
magazine Cambridge Professor David
abelofia looks at the Historical role of
the royal spare and journalist
petronella Wyatt writes in defense of
Camilla the pair joined me now
petronella and David thank you for
joining us on spectator TV now
Patronella to start us off uh you write
in this in the magazine about a defense
of Camilla from Harry's attacks but
before we get into that can you tell us
a bit about your sort of reaction to
Harry's book that's come out this week
and some of the revelations that have uh
that have come from it
um yesterday I think it's quite
extraordinary coming from a member of
the royal family on two levels one being
some of the revelations are so kind of
tawdry you sort of sort of wonder
whether or not
um he thinks he's a kind of footballer
writing his Memoir or um
a TV reality star I mean I think it's
very odd to have that kind of level of
Revelations about
um sexual activity and taking drugs
coming from a member of the royal family
but my view seems to be that this is all
therapy which should never have become
public
but has become public and the other
thought that struck me is that the ghost
writer is too good he's too fluent
it's quite clearly not Harry's voice
because there are passages that are
actually very well written and lyrical
and quotes from
um great authors it doesn't quite
reflect what we know about Harry
do you get the sense maybe that um so
Harry's very very absorbed with what
sort of hurt has caused him but doesn't
rise the hurt is causing others paths
well the extra thing is the total lack
of of empathy
which suggests to me that
um he is very unhappy insists he's
extremely happy but happy people do not
try and make their family miserable and
they don't engage in spite for public
attacks so I really don't buy into his
truth of being happy because a happy
person doesn't behave like that and a
happy person is rather content with the
status quo Etc I
um I mean I I think that he
is um very troubled and
has slight persecution Mania
um but yes but like a lot of people with
persecution Mania because Bertram
Russell wrote about this it's um it's a
condition in which they've failed to see
the other person's point of view
so he fails to see the hurt he's causing
to his brother to his father to Camilla
and also he's completely incapable of
apologizing but anything and keeps
demanding apologies from them
so that's um yeah it's it's
mind-boggling
and David you writes in the magazine
this week about the historical status of
spares as Harry puts himself I mean do
you think Harry's had it worse the most
when you look back in history
well I don't really I mean if you go
back to let's say the 12th century and
you had all these sons of Henry II who
were fighting one another and sometimes
fighting their father joining you know
one moment they'd be friends next moment
they'd be enemies it was very tumultuous
and what struck me very forcibly was you
know if you go back to the past of
course you find people actually taking
up arms killing people in order to try
and grab the throne and so on you can't
do that nowadays but with the modern
media we're looking at a very different
way in which a sort of princely
rebellion takes place it takes place in
public of course and it takes place
through the media through Twitter
through Netflix all that sort of thing
so it's very interesting to compare how
in the 21st century a prince might sort
of stand up and voices objections to
um to his brother to his father and so
on a very very different world and David
what did you make of the relationship
between Harry and William is that is
that something you often see in history
is the brothers in particular who are
clashing
very much so I mean you have examples
where there's a great deal of Harmony if
I'm not mistaken Charles II and James II
they used to walk around Green Park
together in public and so on and they
seem to see one another despite you know
some differences about their religious
policies and so on they they actually
seem to have have been in some sort of
Harmony but it's a constant theme and of
course it's a constant theme because
there's so much to play for there's in
the past it's a question of power uh
it's a question of wealth all these
things which uh younger brothers might
well I'm not just talking about princes
young Brothers might very well sort of
Envy
um the elder brother because he has
automatic access to all of this so it's
quite interesting sometimes to compare
that one thing I do in my article is
sort of comparing that with the
situation where a ruler for instance
divides up his lands among his sons and
sometimes his daughters as well but that
often doesn't solve the problem because
uh that just sort of sets off
competition to grab one's neighbor's
lands and so on so you're back to square
one and the next Generations in sort of
thing happened I mean patch another way
David says it almost seems almost
inevitable that you're gonna end up with
these fallouts with when one sort of
child is spurred does that make you feel
any sympathy for Harry at all or
anything that's pushing in
I quite agree with David's analysis I
think
um what used to be armies
um there's now social media and
streaming giants like Netflix and it is
a way of rebelling Waging War or even
potentially
destroying somebody else's reputation
and as we know it can destroy people's
careers as well but
um I'm not that sorry for Harry because
I think that um spares
in the old days had a much tougher time
and also there are there are many other
cases today for example
um there are people who are the younger
sons of Dukes or Earls who see that
older brother inherit the stately home
and the title and I've known two younger
brothers
um it can't be a picnic but they've
always behaved with Grace and they
haven't made a career out of trashing
their brother because of it or their
family
and I also think that in Harry's case in
some ways it was better to be the spare
because I wouldn't want to be William
the Future King but anything in this
role I think Harry had the advantages of
having the titles of privileges without
the responsibility and that terrible
burden yeah and you write particularly
about Camilla yes do you think Harry is
being particularly unfair to Camilla in
the physical systems of her and
She's accused of being quite scheming
for example what about Ludacris
um that's absolutely ludicrous because
I've I've known her for a very long time
since I was in my late teens and
and she is absolutely incapable of
scheming and she's a very nice woman
she's very anxious about the first time
she met the boys
um she she wasn't even that Keen on
marrying Charles it was Charles who
wanted that she was keen on a more
informal Arrangement she's not
interested in the Limelight she's not
interested in titles unlike Harry for
some weird reason
you know attacks the outdated nature of
the royal family and yet hangs on the
dear life to his titles
uh and I also think it's very
hypocritical of him because he's this
kind of he's now a new age feminist and
yet he's attacking a 75 year old woman
who can't answer back quite unpleasant
language it's very unpleasant I mean
it's the language of
um sort of Game of Thrones come Disney
fairy tales evil stepmothers it's almost
infantile strangely enough I mean David
it does seem you know you talk a lot
about sort of succession and brothers
but it also ties into sort of the
stepmother Trope there a bit doesn't it
as well with Harry and Camilla yes
absolutely I mean there are famous
examples of powerful stepmothers who go
back in his room and I've mentioned
Henry II and there's the famous Eleanor
of Aquitaine whom he married you know
things like this people who sometimes
manage women who manage to exercise
enormous power
um and who could sort of play around
with sons stepsons and so on and dangled
all sorts of offers in front of them so
that's been that's been a constant
really yes but Harry
um in Harry's case I mean
Camilla has nothing to dangle in front
of him no no
she doesn't have anything he wants she
has no lands at her disposal she can't
put him on the throne instead of his
brother but a very interesting point you
make about Eleanor because eventually
though Henry got fed up and locked her
up so
we're looking at that
I want to tell you that to Harry at some
point
you mentioned your piece as well
Patronella that this is the first time
we've seen Harry speaker away from Megan
for quite a long time do you think maybe
people have been a bit unfair to Megan
perhaps and a lot of this is Harry's own
doing it sort of problems I've revised
my opinion of Megan I've also heard from
a very good source that it was Harry who
did more of the screaming and yelling at
staff when they were working Roz and it
was Megan who had to calm him down this
is completely new this is a scoop I
haven't told anyone about this
um so I think that she is much calmer
more conciliary and I think is that
apparent that Harry has lived with their
sort of bitterness and and anger ever
since his mother's death and he hasn't
been able to get rid of it because um
that I mean everything is done with
Megan what the Netflix thing was
it was pretty harmless and it was all
sort of
um it was like home and garden
yeah very Californian but this is this
is bile stuff you know this is
hatred fueled stuff and I I don't think
it's coming from Megan at all
could I then ask I mean where Patronella
do you think you get some of his
vocabulary from because he's been
talking in these interviews about
unconscious bias and it does seem to me
that some of the language how could I
put this politely is is a little Beyond
his normal sort of yes I think I think a
lot of his new language definitely comes
from Megan
um Russ comes from The Ghost Writer
um
but yes he would never have heard of
unconscious bias I mean he was basically
um a kind of upper-class oik
um and a pretty sexist one
and I think Megan has
um yeah she's got him to buy into the
whole California
um
staff and and the therapy stuff and
whatever but I don't think you can blame
her for this what a bitterness that
seems to go right back to his childhood
and although Megan in a way has
facilitated this
um because she's very much a person who
wants
to tell her truth or believes in letting
everything come out rather than the
British way of keeping everything inside
and just soldiering on she's facilitated
it yeah I absolutely agree and you're
right
so I don't think she's created this um
well little monster that now emerges
what do you think the uh the major
audience is here I mean how do we
balance the American audience against
the British audience and of course
there's a worldwide audience as well but
just thinking of those two audiences one
of whom perhaps Megan might be
addressing more is that possible and
Harry Moore yeah trying to get to the
British audience yes I think when it's
Megan she's very conscious of addressing
an American audience and I think Harry
is trying to settle scores and therefore
is very much aimed at his family and a
British audience but the trouble is that
he's gone too far and
we don't really like our royal family
being trashed in this way by a very
privileged young man during a cost of
living crisis uh and I think he has gone
too far and and even with the Americans
because I think the American Media are
now making total fools out of him yeah I
was going to come back to that I mean to
David your excellent point about these
being sort of the modern weapons of war
these sort of social media and press
attacks I mean do you think they're
backfiring as well now on the couple
I I think they are I mean I think that
um so maybe with the leaking of what was
in the book which I must admit I haven't
read
um but I've got a treat
[Laughter]
so much of that just sort of pouring out
and dominating the media for days and
days days and and of course the point
that kept coming across was well the
royal family won't reply and in a
sentence can't reply it wouldn't be
right to reply and that dignified
silence I think actually is winning the
royal family a lot of sympathy yes it
definitely sorry the simple fact we have
a new king and he's made in my view an
excellent start to his his Reign and
everyone is of course Very sympathetic
to him and and seeing how he's adapted
from being Prince of Wales to to being
king
um and he's not in a sense not being
given a chance you know the coronation
hasn't even taken place
brilliant thank you very much David and
thank you petronella thank you
Putin had hoped to freeze out Europe
this winter by denying it Russian gas
people support for Ukraine Mike then
Wayne he thought Owen Matthews
journalist and author of overreach the
inside story of Putin's war in Ukraine
explains in this week's magazine about
why the plan failed he joins me now
Owen thank you for joining us on
spectator TV
um you're right this week about how
Putin's attempt to freeze Europe out has
failed
um viewers are probably familiar with
the way that Europe was reliant on
Russian gas before the Ukraine war
um can you tell us a bit about bit
though about why that's changed and and
what's happened there
uh well the intention of the Kremlin and
the intention of
um uh cranman propaganda was that the
gas dependence that
um numerous American administrations had
warned the Europeans about was going to
come home to roost and that by cutting
off
gas supplies or restricting them the
Russians would bring Europe to his knees
and cut off support for Ukraine that
actually didn't happen for three basic
reasons one it has been an exceptionally
warm winter
secondly that Putin played his gas card
far too early in other words
and right at the beginning of the summer
he began
to threaten in his various technical
reasons
um the gas problems shut down shipments
through the north stream one pipeline
giving Europe a chance to build massive
infrastructure to import liquefied
National and natural gas
and thirdly uh because there was
actually a political resolve on the part
particularly actually an important role
that has been played by Germany's Greens
in fact because they have very
pragmatically and very significantly
sort of dropped their zero carbon
Ambitions or suspended them in favor of
the experience of actually keeping
Europe and Germany you know warm and the
lights on it's an amazing turn around
um you mentioned in your piece as well
that it's almost a Triumph for the free
market as well
um the fact that so much gas has been
able to get to Europe and Germany in
particular can you tell us a bit about
that
well the uh really surprising technical
um part of the story is how quickly uh
U.S and Canadian Oil Majors have been
able to ramp up their LNG liquefied
natural gas production and
um the sales of the top 40 U.S and
Canadian energy companies have gone up
from Two and a Half trillion to three
and a half trillion dollars over the
course of this year because
LNG has basically almost replaced
Russian gas as 30 percent of Europe's
gas consumption that's extraordinary and
obviously that's much more expensive and
it has actually led to some very serious
long-term structural problems for
Europe's economy which is largely
certainly Germany's many sectors are
based on cheap energy which is now no
longer cheap and the the prices have
fallen to pre-war levels in fact October
2021 levels those pre-war levels were
actually already three times higher than
they have been a couple of years before
that's not really to do with the war
that's to do with different factors
firstly zero carbon has actually taken a
huge amount of capacity
um you know of
um other capacity offline for instance
Germany's been closing its nuclear power
stations Italy closed down three nuclear
power stations over the last decade but
nonetheless the basic mirror Miracle the
extraordinary part of this story is how
quickly Europe has adapted to using
North American LNG so you mentioned that
there's a cost to Europe what what's the
cost been to Russia I mean you mentioned
this startling sort of fact in your
piece that I think around a quarter of
Russian State revenues come from gas
prom is that our state spending comes
from gas-prone revenues um so what's
what's the impact of this going to be on
Russia do you think well
um so far it's been disguised
um the impact the disaster that's
unfolding has been disguised by a very
high spike in gas prices over the summer
over which you know during which time
gas problem actually was still and still
continues to sell some
um gas through its pipelines via turkey
some pipelines via bizarrely enough
actually still running via Ukraine and
Slovakia into Central Europe that's
incredible um Disco before you move on
there so Russian gas is going through
Ukraine even but but not that whilst
Europe is essentially boycotting it
yes absolutely I mean there's there's
about 18 18 billion cubic meters of a
year going through three pipelines via
Ukraine and gas problem is paying the
Ukrainian uh State
um oil I guess a gas company uh
Ukrainian after gas
um up to two billion dollars a year to
transport Russian gas to Europe via
Ukraine
um again sort of weird weird example of
the power of capitalism but despite this
Russia's economy is being impacted still
so Russia's economy is is is going to be
impacted massively because gas prom
reported
um last month that it's uh exported down
by 45 and that's pretty extraordinary
um another thing I mean miss my article
is about gas but we shouldn't forget
about oil because
um Euros crude
um is now trading at about 30 a barrel
below the world oil price
and the Euro's crude because it's
sanctioned because there's a limited
number of buyers and so on it's mostly
um uh India and China prime principally
uh but the price has fallen to uh around
50 a barrel for euros crude oil and
given that Russian extraction costs are
very high I mean between 40 42 and 47
barrels dollars a barrel uh that double
whammy of a collapse of oil prices and
the collapse of gas exports are
um actually going to be crippling for
the Russian economy and already there's
a massive budget deficit which is in a
common of course many European countries
but very rare in Russia so already the
economy Minister
reported a um two and a half percent uh
budget deficit and that's that can only
get worse and viewers might be wondering
when you mentioned this in the piece why
Russia can't for example export gas to
more gas to China and and India to sort
of make up the shortfall can you can you
explain a bit about that please uh well
simply because uh Russian Russia doesn't
really have any
LNG
infrastructure in other words all of
Russia's gas or the vast majority of
Russia's gas goes through Pipelines
which is what makes it cheap pint gas is
cheaper than liquefy gas just because
it's very expensive to liquefy and
transport gas and Putin's answer to the
collapse of exports to Europe was
so-called pavarott navastok like the
turn East so Putin said okay well we're
going to sell sell this to China fine
you know currently Russia sells 12
billion cubic meters a year to China it
had sold before the war about 180 cubic
billion cubic meters to Europe so that's
a major difference and the what you need
to sell more is a pipeline there's a
projected pipeline called power of
Siberia 2 which goes from yamal
peninsula in the Russian Arctic across
2400 kilometers will be the by far the
longest gas pipeline ever contemplated
2400 kilometers across Siberia to bring
it to the Chinese market now that
someone has to pay for that
it's not going to be the Chinese power
of Siberia one which already is is is
shipping those uh 12 billion uh cubic
meters that I spoke about
um cost an inordinate amount of money it
was about a 20 billion dollar project
and it was 100 funded by gas problem not
by the Chinese and the Russians
themselves
um said that it was actually not going
to be a profitable project it was a
strategic project so they're going to
require an enormous amount of money an
enormous amount of infrastructure which
they're going to have great difficulty
getting both
um thanks to sanctions so this whole
idea of selling more gas to China is is
sort of Pie in the Sky they need massive
investment either in LNG infrastructure
or in pipeline infrastructure in order
to get it to China right so no no easy
answers for Russia there
um you mentioned in the beginning of the
piece that sort of this Russian attempt
to freeze you about has been kind of
used as a propaganda point in Russia you
mentioned as a sort of an RT video of a
of a European family hoodling for warmth
in their home
um now this doesn't seem to have worked
do you get the sense there's any
acknowledgment inside Russia that this
is backfired or do you think they're
just gonna so blindly go on and ignore
it
um the propaganda is surprisingly going
ahead and ignoring it um there is
actually a sort of semi-official
acknowledgment in that Russia is
actually you know basically
acknowledging that their attempts to
weaponize energy are failing in the in
the form of a an amended decree uh so in
March
the Russian government stipulated that
gas
supply could only be paid in Rubles
um uh now that has actually been amended
um uh earlier this month actually to say
that now actually people who owe gas per
money can just pay in Euros or or
dollars so I mean you know essentially
that's a sort of that that's that's an
official admission that Russia is by no
means as powerful
um in energy as it thought it was and
actually you know to take a step
backwards
it's an illustration of a sort of wider
and deeper problem for Russia is that
Russia's leaders and Russian people tend
to massively over overestimate their
importance in the world they actually
really you can call it a superpower
complex or whatever but actually the
reality was that although Russia was in
fact the biggest energy exporter in the
world it actually accounted for about 10
of world's production I mean that is 10
is significant but it's not 90 it's you
know it's not enough it's enough to
cause any serious problems uh for for
Europe
um
and cause a spike in in gas prices that
we saw over the summer but it's not
enough to bring Europe to its knees it's
a harsh lesson for Putin uh thank you
very much Aaron
and finally critic John Mayer reviews
Quentin Tarantino's new book Cinema
speculation in this week's magazine but
can the director write as well as he
makes films John joins me now
John thank you for joining us on
spectator TV
um you review Cinema speculation by
Quentin Tarantino in this week's
magazine uh can you tell us a bit about
the book is it kind of a memoir is it
essays what kind of oh well the book is
is billed as a memoir somewhat
misleadingly
um it's really a kind of quite long
compendium of um sort of critical
appraisals of films that Quentin
Tarantino was allowed to see as a child
and he sort of goes into
quite quite great depth about his
reactions to them
um when he was kind of exposed to them
at an age and when they were sort of um
quite eccentric childhood viewing for
him yeah you describe as it's quite a
selfish love almost that Tarantino has
of his own uh yeah I mean I think that I
think one thing that you see play out in
the book a bit is that it sort of
embodies a few of the same vices that
you see at work in Quentin Tarantino's
later films where you sort of think that
they're slightly in want of a good edit
it's like the indulgent I'm a slightly
kind of drawn to these um yeah sort of
quite um dogmatic
um sort of uh Daniel moles and
conclusions and things and I I I suppose
that it is a sort of selfish love and
that he um he's very fascinated like all
sort of anoraks are with the kind of
detail of his own reactions
um and not terribly concerned with
whether we're similarly interested in
knowing about that
um it is it is funny it's kind of um
it's slightly kind of indifferent to
what the reader is I'm perhaps
interested to know about and you say his
sort of Love Of Violence comes across
very early on in his life yeah so well
so he has this kind of confrontation
with his mother his mother has an
extremely kind of permissive attitude
which I gather sort of tarantee no hats
himself which is the it's okay to watch
these kinds of catastrophic
demonstrations of violence so long as
they're in context and you kind of think
like what does this what does this
actually rule out and she does have this
you know a couple of times she sort of
says you can't watch he couldn't watch
The Exorcist right and he couldn't watch
Straw Dogs
um although he does say that his child
psychologist watched his Straw Dogs so
they talk about it
um but he I mean detects us chainsaw he
saw that I don't know how old he would
have been when that came out I mean it
is very odd so she has this kind of like
rather sort of unmotivated tendency it's
sort of very occasionally make these
kind of unjustified exceptions but yeah
he sees this extremely these extremely
violent films and is extremely impressed
by them and um you do kind of think it's
fed into his own creative sensibility
this kind of this degree to which he's
very impressed by these kinds of
overwhelming displays and he sort of
suggested it was an interesting point
that he's sort of been emotionally
stunted by this in a way there's almost
fixated on bands and unable to escape it
I mean what do you think I don't know I
don't want to I don't want to claim too
much but he I mean he does he doesn't
seem to be sort of um temperamentally
extremely well balanced and I don't know
how how far the two are connected I mean
I'm it doesn't seem kind of I mean again
the argument that the mother makes
um as far as I recall is that it's sort
of it's okay because watching this kind
of violence won't won't lead you
yourself to be fine but I mean that's
obviously not the only bad thing that
could could happen I mean you could for
example turn out to be Quentin Tarantino
which some people might think is it's
not great
but you know but you know the other bad
things could happen right and talentina
himself has defended a lot of ants in
his films you know what's your view on
the sort of the the gratuitous violence
do you think it's sort of it's justified
by the medium kind of thing
um
I mean like I just yeah I mean it's it's
you can sort of thinking about
Tarantino's films sometimes they kind of
seem like sort of these rather elaborate
excuses for these huge
um these huge kind of um indulgent
displays of fun it's like you know oh
what if we could kill Hitler or like you
know kill the slave owners or or
whatever and so yes it's kind of like I
mean it's kind of very very sort of wish
fulfilling stuff you know it's kind of
almost fetishistic of violence like like
some kinds of porn there's kind of a
little bit of Ingenuity use and kind of
setting up the fantasy and then it's
kind of all like it led you know kind of
just wish fulfilling stuff I mean I
don't know I think it's he's so I think
in a way it has a sort of negative
consequence for his films in a way I
mean I feel a bit bad about this because
I think that I mean some of films his
films are quite enjoyable right
um I think it's just that this is a case
where the kind of creative
Ingenuity and insight doesn't translate
very readily to the kind of appreciative
critical Arena yeah and do you think um
a lot of sort of changed from the era so
he took in his childhood he's sort of
you know it seems like Vance had more of
a capacity to shock back then and do you
think that's been lost and now him
looking back at it almost seems a bit
milk toast though most compared to what
most people are exposed to in terms of
TV and film these days
um I I suppose that that could be true I
mean I think I think things I mean you
know the more films that are made and
the more that standards relax the the
less shocking lots of things are just
just by didn't serve continued exposure
it's interesting though that one of the
things he says is that the most shocking
I mean he says something like the most
shocking scene in a film I ever saw was
the scene in Bambi where the mother gets
gets shot and he's and he sort of
describes his reaction his very kind of
expletive Laden reaction uh when he was
about four years old or something
um and it's I mean it is curious so it's
not I mean I it's not just that the
violence is kind of aesthetically
shocking
um although obviously he does go in for
that
um I think it's more that he sort of he
likes this kind of
um unpredictable transgression
um as in as in the case of Bambi you're
kind of just doing something that is
sort of not allowed so I think that's I
think it's not just I mean although
although obviously he does he does
obviously enjoy um catastrophic violence
yeah I don't know if he's if it's it's
if it doesn't have the same effect
anymore because I mean he has said that
he's going to stop making films
um in and he's correspondingly
threatened to write more books so so
maybe he maybe he thinks he can disturb
more with books now than films brilliant
thank you John
that's it for this week
once again thank you to canacore genuity
wealth management for sponsoring the
week in 60 minutes can Accord will
provide you with the expertise you need
to help you build your wealth with
confidence visit can do wealth.com for
more information
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]